Deku was actually born with a quirk but
it was stolen by All For One according
to a popular Theory Dr ujiko searched
for children with powerful quirks and
then stole their quirks in secret since
we know that Dr ujiko was the one who
told a young Deku he was quirkless many
believe that the doctor lied Deku did
have a powerful Quirk but he just didn't
know it so ujiko secretly stole it and
gave it to all for one and that he just
told Deku that he was quirkless and Deku
believed him some even think that Deku
was the original owner of Decay and that
all for one gave deku's original Quirk
to shigaraki shigaraki's Quirk suddenly
manifested when he was five years old
right after he got dropped off by a
mysterious man but we know that quirks
normally appear before the age of four
suspicious subscribe to anime outpro
right now for more mha theories